This is Radiolab. I'm Jad
Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich.
And today on our program we're looking
at brains and bodies and how sometimes
brains and bodies can
get wildly out of sync.
And let me offer one more
flavor on this theme,
which has to do with something that
neuropsychologist Paul Brocks calls body
Schema Body Schema
is the brains sort of
working model of the body
in order for the brain to keep track
of where you are, where everything is,
it creates an inner representation
of you. Hmm. This is what he thinks.
A model very much in the virtual reality
sense of where it thinks you are in
space and where it thinks you are.
The point is that we,
although we think there's a very solid
distinction between where our bodies and
in the world begins, in fact,
the brain has to work quite hard to
produce this kind of consistency of
experience. And clearly it can go wrong.
This brings us to pilots. Okay.
My name is Dan Folger from I
spent 32 years in the Air Force,
25 that an active flying and uh,
this incidents occurred in July of
1952 at Luke air force base in Arizona.
Our story begins on a normal
training day. It was really hot
in the cockpit, flying down
at low level, below 3000 PDFs,
over a hundred degrees.
And Colonel Dan full, Jim was on
his fifth run, flying in formation,
doing a trading maneuver. He'd
done it a million times before,
but this time something happened.
He pulled the plane up
hard and rolled out. Yeah.
The next thing I knew I was,
eh,
you seem to be sitting up on the back
of the airplane looking down into the
cockpit.
Suddenly he was outside the plane.
I could see what was going
on. I could see the ground,
I could see it with
another airplane. And um,
and when he looked in the cockpit
where he was supposed to be,
he could see
pilot. I was watching myself
not knowing it was me.
What's going on here?
[inaudible]
I'm just going to watch
this for a little while.
So he just sat there on the wing
of his own plane watching himself
fly the plane and just all of a
sudden the curtain snaps nurse.
No, it's not a dream. I'm actually,
that's me in the cockpit and I'm flying
the airplane again. But we began to,
to realize it, Luke, that uh,
in the eight weeks of
training period I was there,
we lost nine pallets.
They died. Yeah. Wow.
And most of them for running into the
ground or running into each other in the
air or an s or thing.
And that's an awful lot of pilot
solutions just in training.
Okay. Fast forward. Many years,
army engineers are studying this problem
and they figured out some stuff about
it, not, yeah. And along
comes this guy, Jim Winter,
Jim Winter, he is his name,
the Federal Aviation Administration
or medical research program.
And he had a radical notion, if we're
going to really understand this, I mean,
really get to the bottom of this.
We have to induce this
experience on purpose.
Make them go blank. Make them, yeah.
Create the conditions that exist in a
fighter jet on the ground in a controlled
environment so they can
study this [inaudible].
His idea was let's put
pilots in a centrifuge,
big a centrifuge and go to
these things at the astronauts.
You've got a 50 foot arm that spins
around and round and around and on the end
of that 50 foot arm does cockpit a
cockpit pretend cockpit mocked up to be
exactly like what a fighter aircraft
might be like with all the controls.
They screens the throttle.
That's where the pilot sits and
gets spun around real fast. I see.
So when we put out a call for volunteers,
I'm Tim says Deck Commander Says Tech.
I met Dr Winter. He was one of the
ones that got involved in his research,
heroically volunteered to
fly the centrifuge and to
deliberately knock himself
out. Scared pilots don't do scared.
[inaudible] 10 [inaudible] pleasure.
This is a recording from the experiment.
The task was to chase
this little airplane.
So I'd sit there and you'd follow it.
And first couple maneuvers would be,
you know, three gs g forces
as the is the, it's like a,
it's like when you're on a roller coaster,
five gs that force that pins
you back in your seat, seven gs,
except really on a roller coaster.
You're only ever gonna experience
about two gs and then nine gs.
Nothing like these guys.
The high g forces herd
the skin on your face, sags,
your eyelids sag so low that you can't
see out from under him and you end up to
tilt your head back to look out from
under your own eyelids that are shaking
down in front of your
face. Meanwhile, yours,
you're tensing all your leg
muscles in your abdominal muscles,
in your arm muscles as hard.
You can learn to use
your body to fight it.
And what you do is you tend to every
muscle from your toes to your calves,
push it out, push it all the way
up, all the way up, okay. And uh,
you take a breath, right?
And you start to say the word Hook
and you hold it for three seconds
and then you finish it off by finishing
the k over the hook. So these pilots,
they sound like they're wrestling
or fighting or something.
Okay.
They're grunting and groaning and
hook
making all these hook noises.
It's like that.
The most you have ever pulled was 12.4 gs.
Just to give you a sense of what
that might feel like for a pilot,
like Tim says, doc who weighs about 200
pounds. Once he makes a 12.4 g turn,
his body goes from 200 pounds,
two to almost 2,500 pounds.
That's like over the weight
of a car because of the
pressure pushing down on it.
Yeah, exactly.
More crucially says when re those g
forces pull blood blood violently from the
brain is pushed from the head down toward
the feet and it pools and the abdomen
and the lower extremities
and when it pools down there,
it can't get back up to the brain
and that's when the problems start.
Does this sound good? No. He, Dr Winter,
he documented a particular sequence that
happens when blood is pulled from the
brain. The first thing you lose is vision.
Usually the first thing to go are your
eyes and you have what's called gray out
or loss of peripheral vision and a,
you start getting tunnel vision and then
you go through blackout where you can
see nothing.
You lose your sight and then if you
take the acceleration forces a little
higher,
you're lose consciousness.
When I woke up,
I remember just sitting there and
I mean this little white space,
I actually had no idea who I was, who
am I, where I was, what I was doing,
why am I doing it?
I'm sitting in this little white ball
and I'm looking around and what is this
all about? I hear this beeping.
There's just quite like
BP and then at that moment
I realize
that I'm in a little room and that I'm
supposed to do something in that one of
the things I'm supposed to do is press
that button. Should I press the button
and at that moment I
realized, holy Macron a pilot.
I'm in an airplane and I'm not flying
it and I grabbed the controls and then
just a giant run.
I'm Tim Sefstadt, Callie macro.
I'm Tim Sestak. I'm Tim Jack.
I'm a pilot. I'm flying in.
The centrifuge all came back
to me at once and I was okay.
Okay. Commando says tech. Dr.
Bennett, how are you feeling again?
I'm like, I can't go home time.
Over the course of 15
years, when are you tested?
About 500 pilots in the center view.
She recorded their experiences,
measured everything he could think
of, and he found a few things.
First that the average blackout lasted
somewhere between 12 and 24 seconds.
One second. Yeah, and wild blacked
out. This is the interesting thing.
Pilots experienced these strange
little visions. Ephesians,
I'll give you an example
of the a individual that
that lost consciousness had
convulsive movements where he was moving
his arms forward and back for about two
or three seconds. When he came to, we
ask him what had happened. He said, uh,
yeah, it was a nice warm day and
I was out at the lake fishing.
All of a sudden I could feel like a,
I had a about a five pound bass on my
line and he was talking and each time he
tugged,
I haven't pulled back and then all of
a sudden I was back in the centrifuge.
I Dunno what happened.
These little dream lifts wintery
thinks this is the brain confused.
It's cut off. Meaning think it
from the brain's perspective.
It's lost the body and yet
the body is convulsing.
Trying to get blood back up to the brain.
Brain has no idea why it's convulsing.
It just sees arms flailing
about and thinks, well,
my arms are jerking back and
forth. I must be best fishing.
The things that are happening around you
frequently get incorporated into those
short dreamless. Here's one of his own.
It turns out he has tested himself
in the centrifuge many times.
A little dream that I had. I was going
down the aisle of a grocery store
floating, if you will. I don't
know that I was on a magic carpet,
but I sure wasn't having to walk and I
was just really motivated to try to pick
up some ice cream.
As I was going down the aisle and
I was moving down through the,
and I could see the freezer. I knew
the ice cream was over there. Yeah.
And I just could not move
my hand over to get it.
The next thing I realized was I was
trying to turn off the buzzer in the
centrifuge with my hand and I
could hear it. I could not move it.
And then just momentarily I got the
ability to have motor control return and I
can turn it off.
Yeah. I don't know where I am. Y'All
don't know where the hell I am.
I thought I was at the
grocery store, by the way.
The other thing is I couldn't control
my arm to get the get the found off
either. It's interesting
this recording,
you're listening to this from a day when
Dr wintery blacked out five times in a
row.
I don't remember anything
on that one. Okay.
And after that fifth run, which you're
about to hear, something weird happened.
Let you take a break. Just a
few seconds. Can't you Brad?
I don't know about that one.
I don't remember starting one
last ride coming up. God, I don't
know if you can take one more.
I'm hesitating because
I'm not ready yet. Okay.
I'm hesitating because I'm
not quite ready yet. Okay.
Just let me know whenever you get ready,
Ron, relax. Let your blood flow
through your brain may be like,
okay, I'm ready for that one
idea. Okay. Bob Checklist.
That istation data station is
ready. Operator. Operator is ready.
Medical medical is ready. Finally,
have you played sort of a final ready?
Haven't been activated. Are you ready?
Yeah. Yeah, I'm going up this time.
Right? I remember going
up on that point. Yes.
Ron. Greg
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the
[inaudible].
Yeah, I think that was enough. At the
end of that last run, doctor winter,
he got off the centrifuge woozy
and stumbled down the hall.
I was really confused when a,
when I got off the centrifusion I
was walking down the hall back to my
laboratory and all of a sudden
I began to realize that uh,
I was above and behind myself and I
could see somebody who was myself walking
down the hall and I said,
Oh man, that's unusual.
Pilots are generally not
new age kind of guys,
but at least 40 of them in wintery
study did report what he just described
having an out of body experience.
We're just still an even smaller sub
sub group reported seeing the classic
tunnel with white light type thing.
All doctor wintery can say is
that that last sub sub group,
they were the ones who
were out the longest.
They had the most intense blackouts.
He's not ready to draw any conclusions
but he does suspect that the dream lists
divisions of seeing yourself from
above even the tunnel and white lights,
it's all part of the same situation.
The brain is just confused
at having lost the body
and peppermint and Kara old
produced that piece for us.
Thank you to them and thanks also to
our pilots. Dan Full Jim, Tim Systemic,
and of course Jim [inaudible]. Hello.
That's all the time we have.
For more information on anything you
heard this hour, visit our website,
radiolab.org and while you are there,
send us an email, our email address.
You know it. Ah, no, come on.
I had never really learned it.
radiolab.org or something like that.
No, that's our website address.
If you would like to email
us, we do like to get email.
The address is radio lab@wnyc.org
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Cohen.
Thanks for listening.